[Applaudissements]
je suis incroyablement reconnaissants je
ne me sens pas meilleure que l'économie
ou qui que ce soit d'ailleurs dans cette
salle nous partageons le même amour
celui du cinéma et nous unissent cette
forme d'expression qui m'a offert un
sublime je ne sais pas ce que je ferais
beau cadeau que le cema a en effet
rejeté youth à saisir l'opportunité
d'utiliser ma voix celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas ces questions
collectivement qu'ils ont très
préoccupant on essaye de nous faire
croire grâce aux différentes alors que
pour moi je vois à une cause commune
d'égalité homme-femme de racisme pour
les autochtones pour les animaux
présents sexuelle on parle dans tous ses
combats la wii de la lutte devrait être
puni six nations show une espèce un
genre ne saurait dominé des zones en
toute impunité
ça je ne peux pas me résoudre je pense
que on est de plus en plus à jour d une
oeuvre la nature et concentrique on
devrait être au coeur de l'univers ont
détruit la nature
voter les ressources considère qu'on a
le droit de faire de l'animation
artificielle sur des droits sur cette
influence sur le lait de cette vache qui
rit est destinée à se vaut et on le met
dans notre cas
dans nos séries qu'on a peur du
changement
on pense que les rimes sacrifices mais
les êtres humains sont beaux ils sont
créatifs
ils sont ingénieux et je pense que usage
social et de la compassion de l'humour
pour présider à tout et aux décisions se
faire venir un réel changement qui sera
bon pour toutes et tous et pour la
planète
alors c'est vrai que moi j'aime a
toujours eu et est très bon et du beau
et cruel à gérer de travailler avec moi
c'est vrai mais tellement de personnes
dans cette salle vont donner de deuxième
chance
je pense que c'est là où on montre le
meilleur les uns les autres quand ils se
pardonne quand on se donne la main son
prochain c'est là que l'humanité est
grande et belle
[Musique]
pis il m'attire court après l'amour et
la paix merci beaucoup
[Musique]